لحديث عن الاشخاص لو الاعاقه في هذه الحرب
التي تشنها اسرائيل هو حديث عن المعاناه
حديث عن الصعوبه وصعوبه الاتصال والحركه
والتواصل وهذه الصعوبه وهذه القسوه التي
ازدادت في هذه الحرب كانت هي متواجده ما
قبل هذه الحرب فالاشخاص ذول اعاقه في
الوضع في الوضع ما قبل الحرب كانوا يعانون
ويواجهون صعوبه كبيره جدا في التنقل نظرا
للحصار الذي المفروض على قطاع غزه منذ
سنوات طويله
[موسيقى]
اينا نستطيع ان نقول بان هذه المعاناه
اصبحت مضاعفه اكثر قسوه اكثر شده على
الاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه في التنقل والحركه في
الحصول على ابسط الامور في الحصول على
الطعام في التواصل مع ذويهم
وتختلف هذه المعاناه وا من اعاقه الى اخرى
فاليوم في هذا في هذه الايام يفقد الاشخاص
ذوي الاعاقه ادواتهم المساعده ا ذوي
الاعاقه الحركيه ا الذي كان يستخدم عكازا
او كرسيا متحركا فقد هذا ال هذه الاداه
الكثير من الاشخاص ذو الاعاقه السمعيه
يواجهون صعوبه جدا في الحصول على صيانه
ومتابعه ل المعينات السمعيه والحصول على
بطاريات ذوي الاعاقه البصريه ايضا يواجهون
صعوبه في التنقل والتواصل مع ذويهم
واقاربهم الشواهد التي وصلتنا وكثير من
هذه الشواهد بان
احد احد ارباب هذه الاسر وهو اب لاسره وجه
اليه اتصال بمغادره البيت لقصف بمغادره
البيت لقصف ولم يمنح الا دقائق معدوده ف
لم يتمكن اي من اخراج ابنته المعاقه حركيا
وام
الطابق بسرعه ومما ادى الى تعرضها لاصابه
وتعرض والدها لاصابه كثير من ذوي الاعاقه
السمعيه يعانون بالحصول على المعلومه
والحصول على ما يحدث وما يدور حولهم لعدم
وجود انترنت جيد يتمكن من خلاله التواصل
مع ذويهم ت فرقوا كثير من الشواهد
الموجوده بانهم موجودين بدار الايواء برغم
كل
ما ما هو صعب وما هو قاسي جدا في بيوت
الايواء وفي دور الايواء الا ان الاشخاص
ذو الاعاقه يعانون معاناه مضاعفه عن
الاشخاص الذين
بدون
اعاقه